from early morning the protesters were
out and angry the vote in the parliament
beyond the barriers drew thousands onto
the streets they succeeded late last
year in bringing their government down
but it has been replaced they claim by
another just as corrupt in a nation
that's on its knees from decades of bad
governance young and older here they
feel they have nothing to lose the roads
around the main square were showered
with teargas effective in dispersing the
crowds but debilitating to
this young boy was carried away by
medics for treatment by mid-morning they
were firing rubber bullets at protesters
who continued to hurl rocks well this is
the main road leading up to the
Parliament building and through the
morning the protesters have been pushing
forward with rocks and the police
responding with their tear gas MPs and
ministers of this new government were
blocked as they tried to reach the
Parliament for the confidence vote one
MP was beaten and filmed this from his
hospital bed patched up he was in the
chamber for the speeches before the vote
to approve or reject this government and
its programme of painful economic
reforms speaking to Sky News the foreign
minister was clear on why the reforms
are needed our warning that will be very
dangerous for the future of the country
to become a failed state but we have
strong confidence in ourselves to say
that you are developing a very concrete
clear realistic roadmap to move on
outside there was an afternoon lull in
violence and a moment to talk to the
protesters about their persistence and
their anger there is no job
opportunities there's no free medical
care there is no free education there is
nothing there's literally nothing
especially for the people living in the
peripheries and this new government is
no good for you no no no in the chamber
beyond them the vote passed but they
need the confidence of the people and
clearly they don't have it Mark Stone
Sky News in Beirut